the first time I saw one was at five and
change in the morning it was soaking in
a hot bath with the lights off and hopes
that my simulated womb would mitigate
some of the effects of sleep deprivation
the damn cat couldn't decide which side
of the door wanted to be on so as nobody
else was home I simply left it ajar at
bursts from the bathroom as fast as I
could to put on a towel I couldn't be
sure what I just seen or even that I'd
seen anything at all
foremost on my mind was the possibility
that I'd dreamt it I searched the entire
house with no result if indeed I had
seen anything it was long gone so it
seemed was the cat I spend most of the
day recovering from the events of the
morning by the time I finally got to bed
the Sun and gone down I woke to a gentle
intermittent nudge
I tried to protest only the discovery
couldn't speak in fact I was completely
paralyzed I couldn't turn to see what
was piercing my neck although perhaps
that was for the best whatever it put in
my neck knocked me out and when I woke
up I was glued to its back with some
sort of sticky fiber the blood rushed to
my head as it descended into the earth I
passed out once again I awakened to the
warm sunlight pouring down through the
hole the things guard us closely though
I see no means of escape yes there are
others down here as well they wait until
we sleep to begin feeding the pain comes
without warning but it's over quickly
the first time they ate me wasn't half
as jarring as what immediately followed
the black jelly has some mysterious
healing effect again and again they feed
on me and every time I wake up without
any sign of injury
it's not perfect however every time it
heals me more mistakes appear for one
thing my hair was falling out there's
also a new finger on my right hand and
some teeth going out of my shoulder the
others are afraid of me I can't say I
blame them the poor fools don't realize
that they'll become like me soon I've
changed so much the books don't
recognize me as human when I leave they
don't try to stop me as I reach the edge
of the cavern a blinding light envelops
me I've made it to freedom of a sort
whatever they are they don't mind when I
hitch a ride Swit stone pillars
punctuate an endless sea of white fog I
feel like a small bird navigating a
petrified forest the only living things
I see are the other bogs in some sort of
floating creature good god what is this
thing
I've got to take a closer look yes
finally or am I not to be so lucky as we
make our way towards the quarry loosens
my binds and begins to speak I ask him
first why the darkness in the distance
is not returned he tells me it was never
there to begin with only an illusion to
prevent prey from wandering too far from
the jelly as a walled structure comes
into view I cry out his glare silences
me I notice upon entry that the door is
made of bones and so are the tents save
a brittle layer of what looks like skin
stretched over them as if anticipating
my questions he holds up a small brick
and explains that his form from a
combination of ground bone dust and glue
made from boiled ligaments his own
remains and those of others fished out
of the black jelly after the bugs are
fed on their flyff assume find myself in
the presence of their leader who has
suffered more mutation than any of us he
spoke of the shafts to the surface world
to which we can never return or rather
not with any permanence raids were
actually quite frequent though it seemed
only the bugs could open the tunnels
I rest prepare my mind and begin to a
sad